welcome back and thank you for joining
us for another episode of the line damn
we are joined today by the incredible
Yvonne orgy and we are ready to dig in
to episode 2 which is low-key distance
so Molly met canola
for the first time it was a little
awkward encounter condolences friendship
why mom I feel about Candela but I know
how Michaels and she feels like as messy
as Molly is she sees the messiness like
nothing gonna work but she's so nice
they all are but she don't think that
there's any jealousy rooted in Molly's
interactions with them and her POV of
canola because canola has been around a
lot and has been occupying a lot of
ESA's time Molly is not a jealous type
but I go front where we were shooting is
up site it's also like this D where MA
it's like when you know your friends
yeah you like I know this is not gonna
end well so what do you think is going
through ESA's mind when lawrence tells
her that he likes condolence it to work
out with her you know I think that's
when it becomes kind of real it was real
when canola dropped the news you know
last episode and I think here is just
like he's saying he likes her and he
wants to he really wants to make an
effort to not have anything cloud her
view of her and I think it hits her in a
realization way but I don't think that
she has fully processed what that means
just yet the thing about cuz I was like
she knows like your weakness is so in
some way it's like like Lauren's like
got his life to get
and there's they're great and she's
great and it's like I'm over here asking
her for help in this episode andrew has
a hard time sort of opening up to Maui
yeah why do you think that is I don't
know if it's that he is like spear
commitment but it's worth because he
pushes in as this like I'm ready to
commit and then it's like he pulls back
so that's what's kind of frustrating and
annoying
tamati because it's like are we you know
it's like we're double dutch in
something - I think it's also very guy
thing - like in last season he was
hunting her yeah where's like the chase
it's like she's like she's rebuffing me
knobs this and then he kind of got her
and then he was a little bit like what
you I got open up man yeah I'm just a
[ __ ] how far will that so in the
spirit of this episode what do you do
when your best friend is getting closer
to someone else well there's some people
I know in Nigeria that I can call and
like make people disappear look so you
kill they're discovered is a big
difference you know this is on camera
what I'm gonna do you dudes don't really
get like oh if we do I think you don't
like his coming around yes yes that is
annoying like if if condole alike
actually like real annoying and you know
like disruptive like I had a buddy of
mine that would always brain we've got
to Vegas and he'd always invite eight
other people and I'm just like oh that's
not it
yeah for me I have blended friend groups
and that's always good with me just
don't leave me out I think we're just
watching you and your friends you've
been really good at making everybody
feel connected like you're loyal like
your loyalty
and she was very admirable and so they
leave me out of some [ __ ] okay well
thank you all so much for winding down
with this we can't wait to see you again
next week
Cheers
[Music]
you